é botar dá a você a prestação portuguesa
e vou tentar explicar por que é que vão
fazer portuguesa porque escolhi é o
português como língua
a apresentação em quito las assim e é
tem como ponto de partida uma mudança
cultural em curso a que eu estava com
tarso
ah ah ah ih ih an e por isso o meu ponto
de partida
nesta é nesta apresentação é uma mudança
cultural a a autora que chama cultura da
consciência está a ocorrer a partida de
sinalização a todos os meios de
comunicação é esta distância são
permitiu fluirá dos conteúdos de uma
forma completamente diferente e mudou
completamente a relação entre produtores
e consumidores pensarem com acham os
sites mais a sites mais populares hoje
são todos os sites facebook e youtube
por exemplo que as partilham as
partilham am a característica serem
produzidos pelos consumidores
isto é hoje a entrada a barreira à
entrada novos autores é muito é mais
baixa do que era no passado essa relação
e assumir conteúdo mudou completa
completamente a cultura que está a
produzir nos nossos dias
claro que está em dimensões positivas
têm dimensões negativas
a questão é esta mudança cultural afeta
a forma é muito visível da cultura de um
modo geral mas afetará a forma como
fazemos ciência e por isso o que nós
sabemos sobre isso sabemos que a
internet é hoje longe o maio tem
substituir os outros meios de
comunicação enquanto fonte de informação
científica
por outro lado sabemos toda a gente que
está na academia que tem hoje uma opção
muito maior para comunicar a seus
resultados as suas investigações
a o seu conhecimento por isso estamos
hoje perante uma situação em que podemos
falar num conhecimento enredo em que o
acesso aberto é cada vez maior
eu não vou hoje entrada aqui é uma
discussão toda é em relação à opa na xxi
mas é uma dimensão muito importante esta
dimensão cultural e temos a
interatividade
por outro lado a ciência está por
exemplo cada vez mais há espaço
informais a em conteúdos que
anteriormente é não encontrava por isso
começa colocar novas questões
particularmente como é que nós somos
capazes de envolver o público é não
cientista a inflação um crescimento ea
conteúdos ciência santeiro aquilo que é
chamado se quiserem saias
o que nós podemos observar é alterações
na forma como nós colhemos estado
como analisa no estado e como divulgar
os resultados que nós podemos assistir a
alterações em toda a cadeia da produção
sente esses são alguns exemplos
os exemplos são imensos mas só alguns
exemplos de como as que estamos a
encontrar novos espaços de comunicação
de ciência este é por exemplo um site
tem a possibilidade de colocar toda uma
série de vídeos e documentos
é óbvio sobre a a dimensões científica
skate é um site é uma comunidade é uma
rede social específica sobre cientistas
hoje tem cerca de 3 milhões de
cientistas inscritos nesta rede social
ou nós não podemos só para pilhar
questionar os cientistas criar pequenas
comunidades
em relação a temas que nos interessam
mas também podemos colocar os nossos
artigos podemos classificar os artigos
dos outros podemos interagir como
tipicamente fazemos numa rede social
este é um outro site sobre a aulas em
vídeo que os mostra também a dimensão
como grande parte da comunicação é uma
comunicação não só enredo mas uma
comunicação visual
eu ia apresentar um pequeno exemplo é só
um outro exemplo um pequeno vídeo é eu
explico já um pouco o que é que este
vídeo é um vídeo sobre um fenômeno que
ocorre a 70 setenta anos e que ocorreu
este mês na costa oeste dos estados
unidos e que tem a ver com o
aparecimento de uma cigarra que vive
debaixo da terra durante 60 anos e
crianças até 12 metros e mais justa
e então o que aconteceu foi que toda a
comunidade científica se mobilizou para
a recolha dos dados sobre é o pequeno
período em que cigarros e médias
empresas criadas 30 milhões de euros o
qual o cálculo que mede um pequeno
período o tempo que produzem se morrem
ficam a os milhões gastos no chão e foi
solta 500 e transmitir novamente
então é um vídeo interessante porque era
um vídeo é evidenciar esse processo ea
solicitar essa comunidade não só do
público em geral mas também a comunidade
científica construiu uns pequenos
aparelhos que colocava da terra que o
dia o calor do solo para tentar prever
quais eram as condições em que merecido
essa é a não ser possível passar o vídeo
isto é um pequeno exemplo muito dizemos
que estão a ocorrer hoje que os outros
precisamente esta participação se dá na
recolha de dados falsos forem a ans a
cigarra é no dia 9 de junho emergiram da
terra é e só se forem é este site vai
modificar o conjunto imenso de dados que
estão lá disponibilizados recolhidos a
partir das pessoas em geral
isso é um outro exemplo que é um blog de
blogs sobre conteúdos científicos
quais são as razões que nós estamos é e
levam apresentar esta esta idéia é que
estamos perante uma transformação
cultural da forma como não só produzimos
mas também como divulgamos a ciência e
no nosso caso ano um português
nós precisamos claramente fazer um
esforço de aproximado os cientistas da
comunicação do cientista se aproximarem
do público no sentido de comunicarem
melhor de uma forma mais eficaz os seus
resultados
o português e daí também a minha escolha
para esta apresentação portuguesa é
essencial
se nós quisermos após aproximados do
público isto é o inglês é essencial
quando estamos a falar ela são as
comunidades acadêmicas
a outro nível científico mais elevado
mas quando nós queremos comunicar com um
público e queremos ser digamos
importantes no espaço lusófono nós
precisamos fazer conteúdos em português
para ficar e tudo é preciso uma grande
falta de conteúdos em português e por
outro lado temos um problema de
literacia científica que também torna de
anos esta ideia é mais importante no
contexto português
por isso o que nós propúnhamos era
tentar criar uma senha sem ver um espaço
onde é nós colocássemos um ecossistema
em que é comunicação visual
ativa para um público é global fosse uma
dimensão central que envolvesse a
participação essa cultura participativa
sul tanto dos novos media prestar uma
forma que o conjunto alargado de
cientistas e estudantes interessados em
conteúdos científicos tivessem espaço
onde pudessem divulgado que os shows os
seus em 13
estou só a conversa o envolvimento da
comunidade e que houvesse uma
purificação no sentido de a chegar nos
públicos que nasçam tipicamente os
públicos que consomem a rotina deles
isto é nós necessitamos de criar uma
ciência ligava com vida das pessoas
forma que lhes desperta é uma cultura
científica que enriqueça a capacidade do
sujeito intervirem na sociedade